- Good evening everyone,
what an exciting day.
It has been wonderful to
see NASA's rover, Perseverance
successfully landing on Mars.
As we celebrate human, scientific
and technological
achievement, let us not forget
that we have the power to transform
not just the outer world
but our inner worlds too.
And that brings me to
our distinguished speaker
and his talk today.
Before introducing Marc Brackett,
our speaker for this evening,
I first wanted to recognize the generosity
of Mr and Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke
whose support has enabled us to bring you
the (indistinct) and discussions.
May I request everyone to mute please.
I'm absolutely delighted to
see that they are here today
and I just wanted to formally remind you
that since we are recording this event,
I would like to request all
of you to mute your videos.
And we will have a brief
Q&A following the talk
and I would like you to
kindly submit your questions
onto the chat and Dr. Ty Kamp
will pass on your questions
and manage the Q&A.
Now to our speaker this evening.
It is my absolute pleasure to introduce
one of our own colleagues, Marc Brackett.
Marc is the Founding Director of the Yale
Center for Emotional Intelligence
and a Professor in the Child Study Center
and at the Yale School of Medicine.
His research has focused
on some of the very,
very big questions like
the role of emotions
and emotional intelligence
in learning, decision-making,
creativity, relationship
quality and mental health.
And he's also thought a
lot about the measurement
of emotional intelligence
and the influences
that emotional intelligence
training has on the health
and performance particularly
workplace performance
and climate for adults
as well as the importance
of this training for young minds.
He has published hundreds
of scholarly articles,
has been recipient of many, many awards,
including the Joseph Zins
Award for his research
on social and emotional learning.
He also has an honorary doctorate
from Manhattanville College.
He's a distinguished scientist
on the National Commission
on Social, Emotional
and Academic Development
and on the board of directors
of the Collaborative
for Academic, Social
and Emotional Learning.
So at this time, while we
are all in this pandemic
and worrying about our sense of isolation,
I think a lot of his work will resonate
and would be extremely
useful and enlightening
for all of us.
He's the lead developer of RULER, sorry,
a systemic evidence-based
approach to social
and emotional learning
that has been adopted
by over 2,000 schools,
preschool through high schools
across the United States
and in many other countries,
including Australia,
China, England, Italy,
Mexico, and Spain.
So what is really interesting about RULER
is that it infuses social
and emotional learning
into what he refers to as
the immune system of schools
by enhancing how school
administrators lead,
how educators teach, students
learn and families parent.
So taking care of the full
ecosystem of integrating
this very important kind of intelligence
that has not been recognized
sufficiently or at least
as important as it actually is.
And research has shown
that this RULER boosts
academic performance,
decrease the school problems
like bullying, enriches classroom climates
and reduces teacher stress and burnout.
So before further, you
know, I could go on and on,
Marc is extremely distinguished.
The work that he has done
is so relevant and so timely
and I am so enthusiastic
about it that, you know,
I could go on and on but today,
he's gonna be talking
to us on his recent book
called "Permission to Feel:
Unlocking the Power of Emotions
to Help Our Kids,
Ourselves and Our Society",
which was released just
a couple of years ago.
And before I turn it over to him,
I just wanted to mention a
couple of upcoming talks.
We have the physicist and
philosopher, Carlo Rovelli
speaking on February 26th and
27th as part of a new series
that we are starting on the nature,
understanding the nature of inference.
So this is a new project that I've started
as part of the Frankie program,
a multidisciplinary exploration
of the nature of inference.
And then we have on March
1st, Susan Hockfield,
who will give us a
distinguished speaker talk
at 4:00 p.m. as well.
And as you all know, Susan Hockfield
is a former provost of Yale
and emeritus president of MIT.
So please keep an eye out for our mailings
and join our mailing list if
you'd like personal information
about events and just to
close, I wanted to mention
that our ongoing learning by
doing project is something that
to solicit simple science
experiments for kids to do.
So I invite all of you to
consider submitting ideas for this
and with that, I would like
to turn it over to Marc.
Marc, welcome and thank you so much
for agreeing to give this talk.
- Thank you, Priya, it's
a pleasure to be here.
Welcome everybody.
It's 4:15 Eastern time on a Thursday
and you're all signed up to
hear some guy from Connecticut
talk about feelings, I think
that's a good thing, right?
What do you think, Priya?
- I think it's a fantastic
thing, it also tells you--
- Before everybody logged
in, you were sharing
like some big news that was
actually kind of fascinating.
Do you mind just sharing
a little bit about that?
- Sure, so NASA just
landed a rover successfully
on the surface of Mars,
it's called Perseverance
and it was sort of a complicated maneuver
to actually land it and so
it's been a great success,
it is happening in real time.
We have not yet gotten actual images
but we know that the landing was a success
and you know, this is a
very difficult, you know,
Mars has been very, very difficult.
Many countries have
tried to land and failed
including India a few years ago.
- Awesome, well, I was saying
to Priya and team like,
I don't know if I can beat that
one presentation today but--
- I don't think there's a competition
between the inner world and
the outer world, as I said,
they are both equally important.
- I appreciate that, thank you.
I just need to be able to use my screen.
Someone, can you enable me please?
Awesome, thank you.
Can you see?
- Yes.
- [Marc] Do you see the screen?
- Yeah.
- Great.
So thank you for the
introduction, Priya and team.
I wanted to just start off by saying that
emotional intelligence has a special place
at Yale University.
Some of you know that Peter Salovey,
the President of Yale was
the founder of the theory
of emotional intelligence back in 1990.
He and my doctoral advisor,
Jack Mayer wrote a theory
that no one really heard of
because when two academics write
a scholarly article, not a lot
of people in the real world
read it but I was one of the people
who got a chance to read it.
And so were some other people
and the term got quite
popularized in the mid 1990s.
And once that happened,
the field really took off
in terms of measurement,
in terms of training,
in terms of thinking about
its application to schools
and homes and workplaces.
And so what I'm gonna share
with you today is a little bit
about the work that we do at the Center
for Emotional Intelligence
that primarily focuses
on education context.
And so I'm excited to share that with you
and I'm gonna focus specifically,
Priya invited me to talk
about my book called "Permission to Feel"
which is essentially a
summary of the 25 years
of my running around the United
States and other countries,
trying to understand why
people are a little bit
reluctant to talk about their feelings
and what are the skills
that help us to use our emotions wisely.
So here we go.
I like to start with quotes
and I think that many of us
have been through multiple pandemics.
We've experienced the coronavirus
for the last almost a year.
We've seen fires burning homes
in California and other places.
We have been made more
aware of systemic racism,
both here at our own university,
in this country, worldwide
and the list goes on, I
think in terms of the traumas
that many people have experienced
and I call myself a chronic
kind of slight neurotic optimist
and so I chose this quote for today.
"And once the storm is over,
"you won't remember how
you made it through,
"how you managed to survive.
"You wouldn't be sure whether
the storm is really over
"but one thing is certain.
"When you come out of the storm,
"you won't be the same
person who walked in."
And that is by Haruki Murakami.
So I wanna make this interactive and oops
and what I'd love to do is
just get people to share.
When you think about that
quote, when you see that quote,
what does it make you think about?
If you can all just get
on your interaction hats,
that would be great.
- [Priya] Yes, please feel
free to type in the chat
and we can read that out.
So there's a comment from Simone who says,
I can get to really be present.
Makes her aware of the present.
We have a request to put
the quote back up again.
- Yes, of course I thought
it was still there, sorry.
- [Priya] Elizabeth
points out that we become
fundamentally changed by our experiences.
And Chris refers to the
suffering in Texas right now.
And Heda talks about
learning more about herself,
strengths and weaknesses.
And John Donatich mentions
that the belief that the self
is adaptable and ever-changing.
A couple of people have
echoed that feeling.
- Thank you, Priya.
One of the things that I
wanna share that I learned
over the last 10 months
is around gratitude.
Oftentimes, we think of gratitude,
like it's a big cliche these days, right?
We're told to write a gratitude journal.
We're told you should be grateful
and certainly, it's important.
But what I was surprised
by in a study that I ran
over the summer, I did
this study by myself.
I was just really curious and I ran it
with about 1,000 participants
and I asked people
across the United States
to describe the things
for which they're grateful.
And what we found in this
study was that people said
my family, my finances, my
security, that I have food,
all kind of the basics
that you might think of.
But one thing that stood out
to me as not being present
on people's lists was things
like grocery store clerks,
the nurses and doctors that are
putting their lives at risk,
the teachers who are suffering
in terms of working from home
or go to school and
put themselves at risk.
And so for me, one of my
takeaways from the pandemic
is just about gratitude.
I go now grocery shopping and
I see a nurse or a doctor,
when I see a first responder,
when I see someone who's
delivering a package
I just think about, my goodness.
I have the privilege to work from home
and I have that safety,
whereas many people don't.
And I think all of us
have learned something
from this pandemic, for sure.
That was just my one takeaway.
Now, this talk is about
emotional intelligence
and I would be doing a weird job
if I didn't ask you how you were feeling.
So at the Center for Emotional
Intelligence, we use a tool
we call The Mood Meter
and it's based in science
that essentially asserts
that how we feel is a product
of two core dimensions
of what's called affect,
our appraisal and our arousal
or our activation levels.
So on the x-axis, it asks you to think
about your pleasantness right now.
From minus five, like this
is the worst experience
of my life to plus five, oh my
goodness, I'm taking an hour
out of my day to just sit
and think about emotion.
So just take a moment and think about
where you're at unpleasantness.
On the y-axis, it says the word energy,
literally think about
your physiology right now.
Do you feel like your body is well rested
and that you've got lots of energy
or do you feel like you
just wanna jump at the bed
and pull the covers over your head?
So what's your body telling you right now,
energized or depleted?
Then we cross our two axes to create our,
(speaking in foreign
language), our mood meter.
Yellow, red, blue and green.
So take a moment and think about
what color you're in today.
Can everyone please do that?
Let's go into our chat
box and what's the color
that represents your
current emotional state?
Yellows, green.
- [Priya] We have a lot of yellows.
- Ty, you can share it if you like.
- [Ty] Yeah sure, we see a
lot of yellows, some greens.
We have a blue, orange, yellow.
Priya is a yellow (chuckles)
and a bunch more greens.
Mostly green and yellow, I'd say.
- Cool.
So maybe this is like a special day
'cause the research that I've done
over the last couple of
months would not indicate
that there are a lot of
people in the yellow and green
but I'm gonna take what I can get today.
What I'd like you to do right
now is convert your color
to a specific feeling word.
What would be the exact
word that you would use
to describe how you're feeling right now?
Ready? You have three
seconds to write that word.
Three, two, one, (snaps).
Curious, relaxed, content,
peaceful, tired, thrilled.
Okay, mellow, hopeful.
Okay, silly, irritated, curious, hopeful.
Just give me a yes or no
in the chat box quickly.
How many of you found
it a little difficult
to go from the broad quadrant
to like that specific word?
So mostly yeses, any
hypotheses around that?
I mean, what might be the
reason that it is moderately
difficult to articulate,
words are not specific enough,
cognitive dissonance,
feeling more than one thing,
not easy to name our feelings.
Not used to practicing
it, lack of vocabulary.
There are a few words in squares.
Nico, there are over 2,000 words
actually on a new study that we ran.
We found 16,000 words, feeling words
but most of us use what?
Two, fine, okay, whatever.
Here's your cheat sheet by the way.
So this is an inside cover
of my buckets, the Mood Meter
with the words, we gave you
the first 100 as a practice,
to just build that vocabulary,
that basic vocabulary.
And you can see here, there are
nuances in terms of building
that self-awareness,
that emotion language.
Now what I'd like you to do
for the next minute or so
is take a moment and
think about the strategy
that you think is gonna best serve you
to get the most out of today.
So many of you said you
were in the yellow and green
and my question for you is
what might be the strategy
that would help you stay there?
Because probably being in the deep red,
if you were enraged or
having feelings of panic,
you probably would have
difficulty concentrating.
If you were in the deep
blue, you might be worrying
or thinking about the support
you need which is okay
but not the best for learning.
So what might be your strategy?
Where does curious learner mode live?
I think that's kind of
motivated, focused, engaged.
What do you think, Laura?
You're gonna be open, pay attention.
How many of you, if you have children,
who've had like complete kind of meltdowns
during the pandemic.
When your kid is having a
meltdown, you say, come on honey,
just be open or come
on, just pay attention?
Crystal is away from the kids.
So that's your strategy, is
giving yourself some space
away from the kids.
Other strategies?
Breathe, listen, same thing.
Are you gonna just tell
your kids, just breathe,
just listen?
Happiness is a choice.
Focus.
It's tough, let me get a raise of hands.
Everyone know how to
raise their hands in Zoom?
Give me a quick raise of hands
if over the last nine months,
you have struggled at
some point or another
with regulating your own feelings.
Okay, a lot of people, let
me ask you another question.
How many of you have struggled,
raise your hands again,
with dealing with other people's feelings?
Okay, so we're all in the
same boat pretty much.
What our research shows at
the Center is the following
that a lot of people are
experiencing some pretty
intense emotions right now.
From over the last nine months,
I think we studied well over 30,000 people
and what we found continuously is anxiety
is the number one emotion
that people report feeling.
When we asked them, well,
how do you wanna feel?
We find very different emotions
during different times.
So over the summer, for example,
we asked a couple thousand
teachers and they said,
we wanna be excited and then
we asked them in the fall
and they said, no,
forget about excitement.
We just want to be appreciated
and valued and supported.
And so what we have here
are interesting phenomenon.
We've got our emotion state,
the one that we're feeling
and then we have our, what
we might call ideal effect
or our hope for emotion state.
And oftentimes, there's a big
discrepancy between the two.
And so that leads us to think
about what's the goal here?
Is the goal to go from that red and blue
and just be in the yellow and green?
What do you think?
I would ask you, what is the goal?
Like what are we supposed to
do with all of our feelings?
What would you say?
Share them, be patient, accept them.
Don't get stuck in any one
feeling, share in order to grow.
Recognize and be aware,
understand and accept them.
I think all of you are
doing pretty well here.
Strife happens but remember
the weather changes, okay.
Well, one thing that I wanna get to today
is that there's a
difficult challenge we have
with this idea of striving for happiness.
You know, the founding
documents of our country
or the report that we
have to pursue happiness.
A colleague who was here
at Yale, June Gruber
who we used to do some research together
did some research on the
dark side of happiness.
That when we strive daily,
like we have this kind of goal
to be happy all the time,
it can lead to a lot of disappointment.
Think about that, you're
bound to be disappointed
if every day you're trying to be happy.
I don't know about you but
like, that's really hard for me.
Anyone relate to that?
That this striving for
happiness can actually backfire.
Does that resonate?
And so maybe we need to think
about it a little differently.
Actually I just did an hour
and a half session today
with this group on toxic positivity,
this idea of like always having to show up
being happy and odd.
And you can imagine when
you're a boss or a parent
or a teacher always like demonstrating
that you're in a good
mood or feeling optimistic
and positive, how that might
just rub people the wrong way.
But it also, what does
that do for the children
that we are raising and teaching?
It makes them think like the
only emotion that matters
is happiness which probably
is not what we want.
So the vision of the Center
for Emotional Intelligence
is to use the power of
emotions to create a healthier
and more innovative and
compassionate society.
I argue in my most recent book
that it starts with ourselves
and giving everyone else this
concept of permission to feel
and I think a lot of you
actually, when I asked you
about what the goal is, you
intuitively got to this point.
So here I am asking you right now.
In whatever role you have
in life, a student, a mom
a dad, a professor, multiple,
you can be all of those roles,
when you think about the
concept of permission to feel,
what does it make you think about?
And just take a moment
and jot down your ideas.
Vulnerability, freewill,
permission to stop failing
sometimes, not being lawyerly.
I actually did a talk for the
general counsel's office here
years ago and one lawyer said to me,
there's no feelings in law.
Let go of our emotions, being human,
no need to have to explain
yourself all the time.
Vulnerability.
How many of you feel
that in your current role
that you have the freedom to be your true,
full feeling self?
Or how many of you feel
like there are times
when actually you need to kind of fake it
or you can't actually
express your honest feelings.
So many of us, right?
Because these concepts don't live
only within us as individuals.
These are concepts that
live in homes and schools
and workplaces, in communities.
And so one of the other things
that we have to think about
is do we have a permission
to feel culture and climate
in our homes, schools and workplaces?
Now I've asked a lot of people
and you're right, Clara,
it depends on the
situation and the emotion.
So over the last year
I've done, I don't know,
a couple hundred presentations
in a couple of years.
And I've asked literally
tens of thousands of people
and have compiled the data,
when you think of this permission to feel,
what are the characteristics?
And what we find is that people
say compassionate, empathic,
nonjudgmental, supportive,
unconditional love,
patient, supportive.
So I wonder A, how many
of you are these things
for yourself right now?
Self-compassionate, being
vulnerable even with yourself,
showing self-care and empathy,
being nonjudgmental of your own feelings.
Or how many of you feel like, you know,
sometimes I could use
some work in this area?
Anyone feel like they could do some work?
And how about with other people?
Especially when you're
experiencing strong,
unpleasant feelings.
It's hard to be compassionate,
empathic, nonjudgmental,
supportive when you're
activated, isn't it?
Now, what I wanna jump to
is the science around this.
So we know from interviewing people
that there are multiple components
of giving oneself permission to feel
but we're at Yale university
and I've done my share
of presentations in different departments.
And I must say that some
people, you know, they're like,
Marc, we like your stories,
we like the anecdotes
but what's the science?
And as Priya told you,
we don't just talk about these things.
We do rigorous research and
I oftentimes tell people
and I think this is the
danger in a lot of our fields,
especially in applied psychology
is that people always ask me,
so Marc, what's your
opinion about something?
And I always tell people like,
I'm fine sharing my opinion
but what you really wanna
know is what is the science
behind what I'm speaking about?
So when I talk about emotion regulation,
it's not what matters is my opinion.
What matters is what the data
show or the science shows
in terms of what works for
people and supporting them
and managing their feelings.
And so I think what's most
important for all of you
to understand is A, we should be blessed
that we have a president
at Yale who took all of the
kind of science from the
1930s and '40s and '50s
and '60s and '70s and '80s and compiled it
into a comprehensive
theory and made it public
that there is a way to be
smart about our feelings.
That emotions are not
disruptive, they're information.
And that they matter for five
really important reasons.
The first is attention,
memory and learning.
Think about it.
If you're bored right
now with my presentation,
you're doing something else.
You're not paying attention
because your emotions
are driving your attentional capacity.
My friend, Mary Helen Immordino-Yang,
she's a neuroscientist, she goes,
we learn what we care about.
Which means that this is
also a relational experience.
Like I am in many ways co-regulating
your experience right now.
Because if I talk like this for an hour
and I just said emotions matter
and I just had a really like
kind of bored facial expression
and really monotone voice.
How many of you would log off?
(participant laughing)
Somebody's laughing
behind the scenes, right?
You'd be like, you may
stay on out of respect
for whatever bizarre reason
but you would be like,
Oh my goodness, I can take
that, I'm gonna lose it.
Has anyone ever had a class
like that where you're like,
the content is something
that you're passionate about
but the presentation is like,
has anyone ever had that?
It's like, it's painful, isn't it?
And so what this tells us
is that emotions are what?
They're relational experiences.
Decision-making, how we feel
influences the choices we make.
Relationship quality.
We say in our Center
that emotions are signals
to approach or avoid.
Has anyone here ever worked with someone
or lived with someone
who is very difficult?
Like just difficult to be with?
And how many of you, when
you worked for that person
or lived with that person
would say to yourself,
gosh, I can't wait to spend
more time with them today.
No, you wake up in the
morning and you're like ooh,
I can't believe I have to deal with this.
Oh, do I have to say hello?
Or at work, you look at
them and you're like,
I'm gonna go the other way.
Because again, think about
this co-regulatory process.
When you look at other
people's facial expressions,
we have memories of the
way they've treated us
and they create activation
levels within us.
Physical and mental health.
One of the studies we did showed
that literally how we feel
and kind of in terms of
the culture and climate
of our organization influences
our own stress levels,
which influences our physical
health, like sleep problems,
our body mass index, which
is an indicator of body fat.
And then finally
performance in creativity.
One of our scientists, her name is Zorana.
She studies the link between
emotions and creativity
and she says, emotions
are the fuel to creativity
but it's our emotional
intelligence that helps us
make that creative
process an actual product.
And this always reminds me
of being a professor here
at Yale, where all of my
students have like amazing grade
point averages and they
all have high test scores,
SAT scores, GREs for graduate school.
And many would think, well,
okay, if academic ability
is the driver of success, then
everyone here should end up
being highly successful
because the range is so tight
but it's the exact reason
why that doesn't matter.
When you have a restriction
of range of a construct,
it can no longer predict outcome.
So like basketball, everyone
who is on a basketball team.
I mean, from what I gather is really tall.
Like, I don't think I'm 5'8
and like eight and a quarter.
So like they're not picking me
to be on any basketball team.
I can't even, you know, I'm
not gonna get into that,
so height no longer really is a predictor
of success in basketball.
Just like at Yale, IQ,
great GPA, test scores
is no longer a predictive variable.
Does this resonate with people?
That means there has to be
other things, other attributes
of who we are that
contribute to our success
and what I'm arguing of course
and have the evidence for
is that a big part of that is
our emotional intelligence.
So my question for all of
you is do you see yourself
as an emotion scientist
or an emotion judge?
Are you curious?
Are you an explorer?
Are you reflective?
Do you want me to get specific
or do you see yourself
as more of like, you know what?
I don't really talk about
feelings, they get in the way.
I had a teacher last
year, say to me, you know,
I check my emotions at the door.
I have to just put them in a
box and leave them outside.
How many of you feel like
you can check your emotions
at the door before you go home,
when you just like go to work really?
Or when you're having a difficult morning,
how many of you like, I'm
just gonna check my emotions?
And I'd leave them in my car
before I go into my office?
It doesn't really work that way.
'Cause our brains don't operate,
we can't pull out the emotion center.
It just doesn't work that way.
When you fail at dealing
with your feelings,
like many of you say you have,
what do you say to yourself?
Let me ask you that right now, be honest,
when you like really mess
up and you say something
that you regret or you eat
something you don't wanna eat,
or you just engage in a behavior
that you didn't want to engage
in because you were upset,
you yelled, you scream, you ignored.
What is the dialogue that
you have with yourself?
I'm a bad person, I'm
so stupid, I screwed up.
I'm so much of a fixed mindset, right?
That emotion judge, right?
And so one of the things
that we try to help people
with is understand A, our
emotions are a femoral
and B, that we are continuous learners
and that's more of a
growth mindset around it.
You fail, it's like, okay, I
can apologize, I can forgive.
I can learn more and I
can do better next time
and so that's basically getting at
that these are hard skills.
Oftentimes, emotions are
thought about as soft skills.
Does that resonate with you?
People think of it as soft
science or soft skills
which by the way, it makes me
crazy since my whole career
is as an emotion scientist
but nevertheless,
that's the mindset and
I always joke around
having been at Yale now for
20 years, has anyone here
at Yale ever met someone
who was really smart
but not emotionally skilled?
Please don't write that
person's name in the chat.
So that leads us to bring in the skills.
So what are the underlying skills?
R-U-L-E-R is the acronym that we use.
Recognizing emotions in self and others.
Understanding the causes and consequences.
Labeling emotions
accurately, having the words,
knowing how and when to
express our feelings.
Having the strategies to regulate them.
So self-awareness and other awareness.
The ability to manage one's own emotions,
the ability to help
others in managing theirs.
So I did a talk a couple of times ago
for a bunch of leaders and I asked them,
what's the psychological
difference between stressed,
overwhelmed, anxious?
Anyone wanna take a stab at that?
Stressed, overwhelmed, anxious.
What's the difference?
Level of intensity, they're the same.
Oh, under the judgment,
different way of expressing.
So what I'm trying to get at with our work
is the granularity in
terms of these differences.
So let me share what I mean.
Stressed, when you're
stressed, think about it.
Stress has to do with
having a lot of demands
but feeling like you just
don't have the resources
to fulfill those demands.
Anxiety is this perception that
there's a lot of uncertainty
around the future, like
for example, vaccinations,
like some of us are waiting.
We don't know when it's gonna happen,
it's uncertain to me around that.
We don't know what the
new strain of the virus,
is that gonna mess things up even more?
That's what puts us in anxiety
It's not stress, that's actual anxiety.
Overwhelmed is when you're
overcome by your emotions.
When you just feel like you
have so much on your plate,
you just can't breathe,
you can't take it anymore.
So people see the differences?
Does that resonate with you?
Now, the question is does it matter?
Does it matter?
Would it matter for us to
be able to be granular?
So I ask you why, why would that matter?
Seriously, why does it matter?
It helps us manage better.
Yeah, there's a saying that we have,
you have to name it to tame it.
You gotta label it to regulate
it and think about it.
If you're working with someone
who you're looking at them
in terms of their behavior.
So let's just try this
right now very quick.
I'm gonna stop sharing.
So imagine I come into your office
I'm a colleague of yours and I'm like,
I can't take it anymore.
(Ty laughing)
Okay, Ty, you're laughing
at me, thanks a lot.
All right, so how am I feeling?
- [Priya] How are you feeling
if somebody comes in--?
- No, no, how am I feeling?
What is the feeling that I'm having?
I can't take it anymore.
- [Ty] Overwhelmed.
- So what happened just then in there?
Did you become the emotion
scientist or the emotion judge?
And why did you become the judge?
Because you attributed emotion to me.
You made an assumption that
my behavior meant something
in terms of anger, frustration,
whatever it might be
and so it's a big deal in our work that
in order to really know
how someone is feeling
A, you have to ask them and
B, they have to tell you
and that means they have to be comfortable
and feel safe to do so.
And we oftentimes grossly make mistakes.
We make big mistakes when
we're judging someone
by their behavior, we have stereotypes,
we have racial stereotypes,
we have gender stereotypes.
We've got, I mean, endless
kinds of stereotypes,
power stereotypes.
And so when we are observing behavior
and we activate stereotypic information,
we're automatically biased in
our interpretation of others.
Does this resonate with everybody?
- [Priya] Yes but Marc, I had
a quick question if I may.
If part of the problem is
that we are not able to even
personally articulate how
we are feeling as we saw.
I mean, isn't that like
the first fundamental layer
of the problem that--?
- It is and so you've
gotta have the language
in order to describe feelings
'cause that's the only way
we know how to communicate in this world.
And then you have to use that language,
understand the reasons for
those different feelings,
states like anger is around injustice
and disappointment is
around unmet expectations.
Then you've gotta get a notice in others.
You gotta confirm that that's
how they're actually feeling
'cause you can't just, if
I start, I hate you, right?
I can't take it, you think I'm angry
but it could be that I'm feeling shame.
I can tell you in my childhood
because I had some serious
bullying in my childhood,
I would come home like angry,
displaying a lot of anger
but it was feeling a
lot of shame and fear.
And my parents constantly
misperceived me as being angry
and then I got in trouble
and then I got punished
and no one really supported
me because I was actually
feeling much deeper emotions like shame.
So yes, it's self-awareness,
building the language,
understanding the strategies
and then building relationships,
giving other people
that permission to feel,
being that emotion scientist with them
and then using that wisely.
So good question, Priya.
- [Priya] And then part of
this masquerading of, you know,
don't we often do that
even as a way to cope?
Like we map something that
is, like you mentioned,
in your example, you map
something that's much more intense
than a shame into something
else, which is anger, right?
So doesn't that serve a
purpose for us personally?
We do that intentionally, don't we?
- Well, I think we do
it because as a society,
we have deemed that
shame is a weak emotion
and so it's certainly
not beneficial, right?
Because we're not gonna get
the supports that we need
to manage the true feeling if
we mask it with another one.
A lot of work we got to do here, Priya.
- [Priya] Thank you very much, yeah.
- So I just wanted to
share a couple more slides.
One is on a study that we
did on emotional intelligence
and supervisor and that's a typo.
This is a study where we looked at
supervisor emotional
intelligence, high and low
and then different aspects of employees.
So skill acquisition, people
feel like they are more likely
to acquire skills when
they have a supervisor
who has higher and emotional intelligence,
much fewer turnover and tensions,
much greater job
satisfaction, less burnout,
slightly more engagement,
less fearful of speaking up.
There was actual more ethics
in a culture in an organization
with a supervisor with higher
emotional intelligence.
So the last thing I'll
share with you today
and then we can take some questions
is that right now during
the pandemic especially,
people have been asking
us what are the strategies
to take care of ourselves, to
take care about the people?
And I'll just end by saying,
the first is this concept
of permission to feel.
Then we've got to help ourselves
regulate those feelings.
We've gotta maybe take that breath.
We also have to do some physical self-care
like making sure that we get enough asleep
and eat nutritious foods and
move as much as possible.
We have the psychological self-care,
taking time to be still and
just doing some fun things.
Social connection, we know
is a big one right now
because we have a pandemic
of loneliness as well.
So how do you remain
connected in this strange,
socially distant world?
Cognitive strategies.
The big one that we focus
on in our work is self-talk.
How many of us have
that negative self-talk,
that automatic habitual
way of being a self-critic
as opposed to someone who
is self compassionate?
And then routines
in terms of setting
yourself up for success.
So I thought maybe we can
just do one little exercise
and maybe we can just do a
little breathing exercise
to bring ourselves into
the present moment.
Let me just take a nice
long inhale and exhale.
Just bring ourselves in to
kind of digest this information
and I'll just wrap up by
sharing a few last things.
So RULER, you heard in my
intro is our center's approach
to teaching social and emotional learning.
Our goal is to get away
from piecemeal approaches
to more systemic models and
we have a theory of change.
And I just wanna say
that one of the things
that we're trying to do in our work
is get people away from
the quick fix mentality.
So like here's your emotional
times workshop, good luck.
This is hard work, I can tell you
as someone who's studied this
and practiced it for 20 years
and still 25 years, 30 years.
We gotta move away from like
the one-size-fits-all thing,
like mindfulness has
become very popular now.
It's very positive and
useful but at the same time,
some people don't benefit from that.
They like other strategies.
We have to think about this
not from an individual's perspective
but from our team at work,
our entire department
and we're doing this at the
Child Study Center right now.
We've had some challenges
over the last seven months
in multiple domains from
people's experiences of racism
to people feeling disconnected
and the only way to get
through this is to take
a systemic approach.
It's not about pulling someone out
and giving them some training.
It really is about shifting
the culture and climate
of the organization and that
means that we have to think
about this as a university.
It means we have to think about this
in terms of the policies
that govern our country.
So for example, detaining
children at borders
probably is not good for
their healthy development.
So how do we inform policy makers, right?
About the principles of
healthy, emotional development?
And so from the micro
level to the macro level.
We have an app that we
call The Mood Meter App,
very excited.
One of our Yale graduates,
his name is Ben Silbermann
who is the founder of Pinterest
is supporting our Center
and the work and we're
building out a new app.
It's gonna be like, just incredible.
So excited about it, it'll
have multiple features.
This is our beta version.
So if you're interested in
plotting your emotions over time,
you can download that and let me wrap up
and then we'll take just a few questions.
First, you gotta evaluate your routines.
Is your day working for you?
Try to be a preventionist.
Surround yourself with
people who are calming.
I can't tell you the power
of the presence of someone
who can bring your
nervous system levels down
and your sympathetic arousal down.
Be aware of emotional contagion.
It works for both pleasant
and unpleasant emotions.
So a stressed out parent
is a stressed out home.
A stressed out boss is
a stressed out workplace
and so we have to monitor those feelings.
I say be an uncle Marvin,
that was the person who
was my hero in life.
That presence of someone
caring, as I mentioned.
Think about positive empathy
in addition to traditional empathy.
Positive empathy is just
showing that you care
to someone else.
Giving a compliment, not a
fake compliment, a real one
and you won't believe how far that will go
in terms of shifting their biochemicals.
Maybe consider your best self.
How do you wanna be seen and
talked about and experienced?
Lastly, as you know, my work
is about emotion and arguing
and I'll argue this until the end of time
that it starts with giving
ourselves and others
the permission to be
our fulfilling selves.
There's no such thing as a bad emotion.
People have deemed that anxiety is bad
and happiness is good.
That's not a healthy way
of thinking about it,
all emotions are experiences,
they're information.
Strive to be that emotion
scientist, not the judge.
Remember, it's about
using our emotions wisely.
I think we have to
appreciate that this domain
of intelligence operates
and functions differently
than traditional cognitive abilities.
It's much harder as we've
seen in the pandemic.
The levels of anxiety and
depression have been higher
than we've seen in decades
which means that it's demonstrating
that it's hard to apply these skills,
when the sand unfortunately
gets kicked in your face.
And so we have to be mindful of that
and I think be more prevention
focused, as I said earlier.
Maybe be the role model for
your family and your friends
and your colleagues, be open
to apologizing and forgiving
and repairing, getting the
help that you might need,
focus on systemic change.
And I like to end in lofty ways
just because that's the way I operate.
I have a lot of hope for this work.
I think that we're finally
as a nation taking seriously
this other side of the report card.
Still we have another couple
of decades to infuse it
into the immune system of our nation
but going back to the
center's mission and vision,
I think if we take seriously
our own and others'
emotion skills, we can build a
healthier and more equitable,
innovative and compassionate society.
And as I run around the
world or I used to anyway
and visiting schools, for
example, here in Connecticut,
some of the most high poverty
areas, I always ask myself,
will this child have the opportunities
and learn the knowledge and the skills
to achieve their dreams?
And I'm still not convinced
that we're there yet.
And so I'll end by saying, it's
really our moral obligation
to take seriously our emotional lives
and the emotional lives of others
and I hope that this was enjoyable
and let's take a couple
of minutes of questions.
Thank you.
And if you want more information, oops,
let me just skip that.
That's the name of my book,
it's "Permission to Feel".
My website is where you can go
to learn more about the book
and also has links to our center
and also to our school-based curriculum.
So you can just go there
and it'll drive you
to other resources and
on that note, thank you.
- First question, Marc, thank you so much.
- [Priya] Thank you so much, Marc.
That was a wonderful and
Ty, did you wanna go ahead
and handle the question so that
people have a chance to ask?
That was absolutely fantastic.
I wish we could have had
you for many more hours
for sort of more detailed session.
I think even this recognition
that you are offering us
is just so important right now especially.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- [Priya] I will defer now to
Ty to handle the questions.
- Sure, first question
from the chat, thank you
and thank you, Marc.
Why would engagement with
both a high, low supervisor
emotional intelligence be
so close on that graph?
Seems like a low emotional
intelligence supervisor
would be discouraging to be engaged.
- That's a good question
and so I'm not 100% certain
but what I would say is
that it just might be that
for most people, if
they are like they care
or they're interested
in their actual workload
and whatever their job is
that it's less effected,
it's slightly affected.
But I think and maybe people
like to see themselves
as being engaged in their work
if there's a little bit
of method problems there.
But what I think is more interesting is,
or not more interesting
but I would say relevant
is that engagement can also,
we found in another study
that engagement and burnout
are not inversely related.
That there are people
who are highly engaged
and also highly burnt out, about 20 to 25%
of the U.S. workforce reports that.
What we find is that those people are,
they're doing their work
but deep inside they're really burnt
and they're looking for other jobs
and so that engagement can
be masked also with burnout.
- Another question.
You so insightfully
talked about the necessity
of being able to properly
name our emotions.
What to do then with children,
especially young children
because we wanna start them
as parents at a young age
on the path to emotional intelligence.
So what are some of your
recommendations for parents
and dealing with young children?
- Yeah, so I don't know.
I'm embarrassing to plug my book
but that's a lot of my book is about that.
But just to give you like the basics
is A, you gotta be the role model.
You have to be a parent
who is not gonna be
that toxically positive
parent that's, dad is great.
Or mommy is great,
everything's fine, right?
A lot of people, we just
desperately want our kids
to be happy all the time and
so we fake how we're feeling
and we try to convince our
kids that they're happier
than they actually are
and I think that that's
a disservice to kids
when they're having their feelings.
The best thing to do is
to validate those feelings
and help them label them
properly and then find out,
what they need to support
them in managing that feeling.
And then you'll have kids
who have greater wellbeing.
They won't necessarily
be happy all the time
but I think the goal
for wellbeing might be
actually better than
the goal for happiness.
- And is that what your uncle Marvin did?
Was that the side of the story?
- He was like, gosh, you
know, you're being bullied.
You've had terrible trauma in your life.
Like it's understandable,
let's talk about it
as opposed to let's ignore
it, try to get rid of it.
- Wow, okay.
- Should we do one more?
- Yup, just going through the chat here.
All participants are welcome
to put questions in the chat.
A lot of compliments on how
well received your talk was.
- Appreciate that, thank you.
- [Ty] Okay.
- That's cool, Susan.
Well, thank you for sharing.
Glad to see that you're doing RULER.
Well, Ty, thank you.
- [Priya] Yeah, thank you so
much, Marc for this wonderful--
- Hey Rob, just so you know
this is Rob, I'm outing him
but Rob and I were roommates in college.
So that's 32 years ago, Rob.
- [Rob] Yeah, thanks for the reminder.
(laughs)
Great job, Marc.
- Thanks Rob, good to see you.
- [Priya] Thank you very much.
- Take care, everybody.
- [Ty] Thanks so much,
thanks Marc, bye bye.